[Music]
calling all vixens or serpents in my
case welcome back to Sweetwater secrets
as always I'm your fearless riverdale
leader Leonid Galera and this week's
preview show is going to be all about
Riverdale's newest character Tony topes
I'm Tony so fast now I was trying to
look really cool just like Tony it's
just family loyalty but it's really hot
in here because there's a lot of light
so I'm going to take this jacket off but
you guys know that it was there okay now
today I'll be bringing you exclusive
interviews with Cole Sprouse and Lindley
Reinhart talking all about Tony and the
possible tension she could be bringing
to bug heads relationship so brace
yourselves but first if you'll recall we
were just introduced to Tony in chapter
16 the watcher in the woods when she
volunteered to show judgey the ropes of
Southside high now she seems really
sweet and smart and I even gave her a
kiss in my hisses and kisses roundup and
when you guys hit the comments a lot of
you guys did the same now here's what
she had to say Claudio was a K says
kisses I love Tony topes me too girl
Sophia loves pizza which welcome back
said kisses I really like Tony topes
she's awesome and that bug had seen
smirky face emoji
oh yes that bug had seen
sorry I didn't see that but you guys
just because Tony gave us a great first
impression that doesn't mean that I'm
not cautious about her no matter how
friendly and sweet she seems she could
have some seriously vicious intentions
so let's break down what we do know
about Tony from the Archie comics now
she's described as quote a tough girl
with signature pink hair she likes food
especially cupcakes creativity and
Jughead
hmm now also in the Archie comics it was
hinted that Tony is bisexual
now when each hand line actually first
broke the news that Vanessa Morgan would
be coming on to play Tony Riverdale
showrunner Roberto aguirre-sacasa told
me that season two will quote explore
the topic of Tony sexuality and that she
could be trouble for Betty and jugheads
relationship and on that note here's
what Cole and Lily had to tell me when I
asked about Tony's true intentions
I loved the introduction of Tony topes
right
she's so great such a dynamic character
how is she gonna be helping Jughead as
he is getting into the thick of things
it's all said hi it's kind of up in the
air whether she's actually helping or
hindering Jughead he's being surrounded
by different people different kinds of
people people who are very different
from betty tony topaz the opposite of
betty and she's this new girl in
jugheads life and i don't want to say
it's necessarily a love triangle but
you're on the three of them I know she
has her own agenda and it's revealed
what her agenda is over time but it's
not quite clear if joining the Serpent's
is something that one Jughead wants or
two is something that's actually good
for him she does cause a rift a little
bit kind of a change in Betty's world it
kind of maybe catches her in her tracks
a little bit Tony is trying to coax him
into the surface and whether or not that
has repercussions for Jughead is left to
be seen throughout the season but she's
a character that resonates with Jughead
mentally quite a bit so he has an easy
time not seeing the red flags I think it
definitely she causes a little bit a
little bit of trouble but you know it's
not she's not like an enemy to the bug
head
and I don't really think of her that
character that way she's a lot more of
just like jugheads Ally on the south
side in my opinion interesting now take
note that Cole said that Tony has her
own agenda that will be revealed and I
can tell you that as we move into
chapter 17 the town that dreaded sundown
you will definitely be seeing a
completely different side to Tony now
here's my super wild thoughts so bear
with me right now
what if Tony was behind Jughead getting
jumped by the Ghoulies now she would
have known that he was there working
late so she could have tipped them off
and that would have been the perfect way
to get juggy to join the protection of
the Serpent's hmm now here's what all
you guys had to say about Tony meta
hewan II says I feel like Tony is going
to ruin bug heads relationship and that
she's behind the beat up of Jughead hey
same thought girl like your brain great
minds great minds a leaf it says I think
that Tony Tobi's might have a slight
crush on Betty
instead of Jughead it would be an
interesting plot twist and even though I
don't like stereotypes I'd like to see
that I like where your brains going and
donut yay 10 which that is an amazing
handle name said conspiracies I've heard
because Tony is bisexual she's gonna
have a thing for Betty not Jughead
Cheryl's gonna end up with Betty's
long-lost brother because some of the
cast has said there was going to be more
incest now that's an interesting note
there donut yay 10 because I personally
am rooting for Tony and Cheryl to become
a couple and I'll have plenty more on
that subject from Madeline patch herself
so stay tuned all right guys now that
does it for this week's preview show of
Sweetwater secrets now hit the comments
right now and let me know what you think
about Tony topes is she a friend or a
foe then check back after you watch
chapter 17 for a full-blown freak out of
the episodes most shocking moment also I
know a lot of you guys were wishing that
you could subscribe directly to
Sweetwater secrets and I've got great
news for you now if you're watching this
on the YouTube app which most of you
probably are click the link in my
description below and it'll take you to
the Sweetwater secrets series page and
there you will see a little bell ring
the bill aka push it and you'll
automatically be notified
when a new episode of sweet butter
secrets is posted to et's youtube
channel thanks so much for tuning in
guys and I'll see you next time for more
sweet utt our secrets later babes
[Music]
you